joining us now two men kicked off the
january 6 committee congressman jim
banks congressman jim jordan jim jordan
i'll start with you were you given a
reason why you were kicked off the
committee one and number two you just
heard from the chief of staff of the
department of defense confirmed by the
inspector general of the department of
defense uh that all the things they did
were correct um
why were you kicked off the committee
and what are your thoughts about the
issue of nancy pelosi and the mayor of
d.c rejecting donald trump's call for
troops two days ahead of time
no i think that's why we were kicked off
because we jim and i were raising that
question and then we we found out daniel
she wasn't going to last several on the
committee first time in american history
frankly sean first time this has ever
happened and i think she's afraid of
getting to the truth why is it the
sergeant of arms uh sergeant-at-arms
office will not nancy pelosi will not
let them release the communications and
documents that surround this whole
decision why is that they won't release
the information so yeah we got
conflicting testimony between the
capitol hill police who said the police
chief said he requested the national
guard be there on january 6.
sergeant-at-arms says no you did it
conflicting testimony so one guy says we
asked for it one guy says we did it the
guy who didn't is the one who answers
directly to the speaker's office and she
that office will not release the
communications between the speaker's
office and the sergeant-at-arms and
other communications the
sergeant-at-arms have so we know that's
the reason why jim and i weren't allowed
to be on the maybe i've just asked that
question maybe i've been cynical in my
old age why do i think probably they've
been bleach bit by this time or smash
with a hammer um congressman banks let
me ask you why doesn't this committee
call before its subpoena nancy pelosi
the sergeant-at-arms
the capitol police chief and mayor
muriel bowser why aren't they being
called
sean the most important thing i read
today on the internet was a piece from
former speaker newt gingrich in newsweek
who said
he knows firsthand as a former speaker
of the house that it is the speaker of
the house's responsibility to oversee
the capitol police and oversee capital
security and it gets very uncomfortable
when you go down that path you realize
that the breadcrumbs lead to nancy
pelosi's office and that distracts from
the circus the narrative today it was
january 6 the musical at the capitol it
just that going down and following the
breadcrumbs to nancy pelosi's office
means that she was negligent she oversaw
a systemic breakdown of security of at
the highest levels of the capitol police
that led led to the capital being
unsecured on january 6. that gets very
uncomfortable for democrats to go down
that path
so we have jim jordan only people that
voted to impeach the president to the
two republicans that are the biggest
never trumpers
uh you two are both kicked off the
committee i don't see any effort to
subpoena nancy pelosi or or the capitol
police chief or the sergeant-at-arms or
mayor bowser my question is does that
then make this a a sham committee with a
predetermined outcome whose only goal is
to bludgeon trump again and with the
hopes of purging him from any future
political run
no exactly right shows how partisan is
and frankly how out of touch it is think
about it sean we've had record crime
record inflation record number of
illegal immigrants entered the country
over the last year and what are the
democrats doing today oh they're having
hamilton the cast of hamilton come sing
a song on zoom for goodness sake so it
shows how out of touch they are how how
much they want to go after president
trump but the most disgusting part of
the day was what you reference in your
monologue where the vice president of
the united states says this is january 6
was the equivalent to pearl harbor was
the equivalent to to 9 11. tell that to
the granddaughter whose grandfather was
gave his life on d-day tell that to the
son who's whose dad was one of the
firefighters who went into the tower on
9 11. or frankly tell that to max
soviet's family max soviet one of the 13
people from our district one of the 13
people who gave his life for our country
this summer go tell that to them that
this is from the same lady who was
raising money to bail people out of jail
who attacked law enforcement in the
summer of 2020. go tell that to those
individuals that's how ridiculous and
out of touch the democrats
are jim banks i only have 30 seconds we
lost dozens of americans thousands of
injured cops billions of in property
damage uh the democrats either was
silent or said the protests in the
summer of 2020 were mostly peaceful
where's that committee
it doesn't exist 2400 police officers
were hospitalized from blm riots in the
summer of 2020 sean and i've never heard
a democrat breathe a single word about
those police officers because it doesn't
fit into their anti-trump their
anti-trump voter narrative they don't
want to talk about that they obviously
want to create the circus that they've
created today i'm sure you both have
great confidence in adam schiff who led
one of the greatest post-election lives
for three and a half years and dragged
the country through hell he sits on this
committee you can't make this adam's
shift up you really can't thank you both
appreciate it you should be on the
committee it shows how corrupt they are
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else